[Music]
software manufacturer s ap is investing
in a vast new market
Marcus Noga the head of machine learning
at the firm wants to get artificial
intelligence running across all sectors
we have a vision the intelligent company
we want business processes which are
often very rigid repetitive and
extensive to run themselves through
machine learning meaning that the 80% of
a process which involves routine tasks
can be carried out entirely by the
software alone this program evaluates
the visibility of sponsors logos during
TV broadcasts of sporting events until
now that's been a tedious manual task
you can make an analysis here you can
see very clearly which logo can be seen
at intervals for how long in sa peas
Innovation Center in the German city of
Potsdam data experts are developing new
applications for machine learning
machine learning is about the computer
learning from data rather than being
specifically programmed that enables us
to process fundamentally restructured
information such as natural speech the
spoken word the written word pictures or
videos in completely new ways in machine
learning computers analyze data and
identify patterns like humans learning
from experience the more data available
the more reliably a program can make its
own decisions berlin startups are
already using the technology in farm
cultivates vegetables and herbs and
computer-controlled modules on location
and supermarkets or restaurants the data
collected on growth and consumption is
aimed at obtaining a perfect match
between cultivation and demand
but while in farms data volumes are
growing only slowly online retailer
outfitter II has collected enormous
amounts outfitter II stylists put
together wardrobes for half a million
men from eight countries entirely
according to their tastes and needs
machine learning helps the stylists
cater to a customer's tastes more
accurately with each order the software
gradually restricts the available
selection based on the knowledge of
goods previously ordered and returned
Steven Lam is outfitter ease chief data
officer he says adopting intelligent
software has improved sales though it
still wouldn't be possible to replace
the online retailers 150 stylists with
computers we want to create the perfect
symbiosis between stylist and machine a
stylist will always be able to do things
better than any algorithm such as
recognizing trends and the entire
communication process with the customer
is something a stylist will always do
better than a machine but when it comes
to these enormous data volumes the
statistics the number crunching a
machine offers a clear advantage in
hiding client photo that's why companies
will soon be using computers for routine
tasks rather than people if things were
up to sa P's Markus Noga artificial
intelligence will soon be hard at work
in every company
you
[Music]